this is going to be a very bad film it
will teach you nothing you'll wander at
the end where those few minutes of your
life have gone you'll feel bitter
resentful and increasingly furious now
that's a tiny example of what pessimism
can do for you it prepares you for the
worst reduces the tension of
expectations protects you from
disappointment and might even make you
laugh of it it should be a recipe for
life we live in an absurdly and
painfully optimistic world mostly that's
the result of all the businesses out
there trying to sell us things and
understandably using cheerfulness to do
it and partly it's the influence of
Technology which is always getting
better coloring our view of life as a
whole which often isn't improving in the
process we've lost sight of the wisdom
seeing the glass half-empty for
centuries
with religions peddled our messages
Buddhism told his followers that life
was suffering Christianity spoke of the
fallen state of mankind and of the
inevitability of earthly imperfection
and was helpful
it kept our expectations in check the
psychologist William James came up with
an equation happiness equals
expectations over reality so there are
two ways to ensure contentment change
reality or change expectations
pessimists know to reduce the
expectations good pessimists rehearse
some key lessons to themselves everyday
life generally goes wrong everyone is
worried and sad most of the time it's
normal to have very big regrets around
careers the only people we can think of
as normal a people we don't yet know
very well it's hard to be happy for more
than 50 minutes almost all your hope is
going to be dashed mediocrity is the
norm today however grim will probably be
one of those days you end up looking
back on and wondering why you didn't
appreciate more fully that's how much
worse it will eventually
don't think of us pessimists as grim the
gap between what should be and what is
can be filled with laughter a generous
laughter born of certainty that today
will go wrong tomorrow will probably be
even worse until the worst of all
happens but that's okay
you